yeah i mean i'm stressed out i'll be
honest with you guys i don't want to
lose to olive garden
hey everyone i'm joe sasto i'm a chef
here in california for the challenge
today i'm making my version of the
italian american classic chicken
parmigiana before it can be delivered
from olive garden now i have a fair bit
of competition experience so i'm
confident that i'll be able to uh live
up to this challenge today but first
things first before we even get into the
recipe what
i need to place the order one order of
chicken parm i'm not gonna start cooking
until i get
the confirmation that my order is placed
just so everything is fair
the anticipation is killing me do you
have butterflies to do something
little butterflies going on they're a
pretty big competitor
oh here we are my order has been placed
ready set
go alright so i know i'll garden send
some pasta with their chicken parm so
i'm gonna make my own pasta i have some
leftover sheets here but of course you
could always use dry pasta or something
from the box that's totally fine i'm
gonna dust a little bit of semolina
flour
using a rolling pin we could go right
over
the pasta dough and this will actually
cut
the pasta into beautiful square noodles
and then just gotta rub your fingers on
it
and the noodles fall right through this
slides out the bottom
i'm going to set these aside back to
work getting started here on
my sasto family marinara i have a
white onion here i'm just going to cut
the root and the stem
off peel the onion i'm going to cut this
into
thick rings crushing the garlic and
we're going to fry that
in some olive oil this is a quick
caramelization i'm going to let this go
for one or two more minutes
we're going for brown soft almost
translucent
i want to keep all of that oil in the
pot so make sure to drain these
in a slotted spoon now occasionally i'll
let this go a little longer we're
against the cloth today
we're going to speed this process along
dried herbs i'm going to toast those up
in my olive oil and then i have my
crushed tomatoes
just be careful no splash them here a
little bit of
sugar here and then of course can't
forget the salt i'm going to stir
this all together i'm going to set this
aside just to simmer until i'm ready to
use it i have my chicken thighs i have
a zip top bag here that i've cut the
sides in and you know what i actually
like to do
is always spray the inside of my bag
this tiny bit of water
just kind of like helps the meat spread
out and that way it's not sticking to
the bag i don't have a mallet or
anything so
i'm gonna use a pot one thigh down you
can see here
it is flattened out it's even you know
olive garden uses chicken breasts
i just prefer the thighs over the
breasts i think they're juicier it's
dark meat i just like the way they cook
better last one
i'm doing three i want one for safety
and i'm hungry
the trick here is to kind of like hit
from the center and push
outwards it's a controlled pound next we
have our
breading station set up here i have eggs
into a container a little salt and
pepper in here i'm gonna beat up our
eggs
get a pan on the stovetop here we're
going medium high heat for frying
and i'm gonna fry in olive oil it's
gonna make it that much better flour is
our next component here
the third part of the breading procedure
here seasoned
italian breadcrumbs and panko mix them
together
i like to put a little bit of cheese
into my breadcrumb mix
i think that kind of takes it up
why did the power gets back all right
power's back we just tripped the uh the
breaker over there no worries
and then i like to bump up my italian
breadcrumb mixer a little garlic
powder uh parsley flakes so i'm gonna go
a little salt and pepper
in my flour and my bread crumbs so that
way as
i'm dredging my chicken it's all getting
seasoned throughout and there's not just
seasoning on one layer
don't forget to season your chicken guys
and we're going to go flower first
i'm stressed out here i'll be honest
with you guys i don't want to lose the
olive garden
push the flour into the chicken dust off
the extra flour
into the egg right to the bread crumb
mixture fairly straightforward process
we're not in a bad spot guys we're doing
pretty good i don't want anybody
stressing out i'm the only one that's
getting stressed out today
chicken up i'm gonna press the bread
crumb mixture into the chicken
set that aside clean our hands
we're ready to fry here into the oil
very gently i'm going skin side down
away from me
so this step we're not cooking the
chicken all the way through i'm going
for about 80 90
cook the last 10 is going to happen in
the oven we got nice and golden brown
on our skin side here i'm going to flip
over very gently
so we're gonna fry i want to say about
three to four minutes per side
and i think i have enough room here to
land another
chicken i don't want to crowd my pan but
we're gonna break a couple of little
stir today
right epa 30 minutes eta 30 minutes
our driver just let us know i think
they're picking up the order now from
the olive garden
i'm feeling good 30 minutes is a good
amount of time to bring this all
together
first piece coming out i'm going to land
over here on the side and make a little
room for my
final piece oh look at that that is
crispy
crunchy fried chicken goodness right
there
get a little drain onto our landing rack
here and our last
guy is frying up we're looking good good
color on both sides
and then i'm going to top my chicken i'm
only doing two of my thighs here so it
could all fit onto one tray
so i'm gonna go probably a ladle of
sauce on each
i'm gonna purposely not cover the entire
chicken
keeps some crispy bits around the edge
and the whole thing isn't drenched in
sauce
and then of course i got a blend of
cheese here mozzarella
provolone parmesan and
we're gonna go pretty generous here i'm
gonna go stick this
in the oven and cook my pasta i'm
seasoning my water with salt
bring this to a boil and then of course
my
pasta give it a little stir and because
this is fresh pasta it's only gonna take
about a minute go with the noodles
straight into the sauce over here on the
side i don't like to just pour my sauce
on top of my noodles i like to do it
much like the italians would
just kind of marrying of the noodles and
the sauce together as one so i'm going
to use a little bit of this starchy
cooking water
just a splash and that's going to help
all of my noodles coat themselves with
that gravy
and we are ready to plate i'm going to
use these big pieces of basil
in my sauce here we go
nice noodle twirl this is gonna go on
the side of the plate
i got some of these basil leaves and i'm
ready for the chicken parm
flying in towel check that out
that's probably the fastest chicken farm
i've ever made
that's how you know you did it right all
of that cheesy goodness
i got a little bit of uh grated parm
here just to finish off the pasta
a few of these basil leaves i'm done
count it time time that's it
i did it i made pasta chicken parmigiana
faster
than olive garden i want to try this
right now but for all fairness we're
going to wait for olive garden to get
here
the moment of truth to keep everything
even i'm going to plate this
and eat them side by side just to kind
of see what we're looking at here we
have olive garden on one side
mine on the other chicken parmigiana
aesthetically i think i'm winning we'll
start with this spaghetti
a little bit of tomato sauce
we got uh these two chicken breasts i'm
gonna cut it right
right down the middle the chicken tastes
seasoned
which is nice there's some salt and
pepper on there on to mine
i'll tell you it was just like a
marinara off
already but it's about the chicken parm
so let's get in here
nice hearty pieces of chicken
now that's chicken parm super juicy
finish with more of that like sass no
marinara on top
the mozzarella fresh basil the race and
the taste test
i think we have a clear winner over here
today i won
that was fun today we challenged all
garden i had to beat the delivery driver
which i did but
only barely then we did a side-by-side
taste test
and it turns out you can actually make
better than olive garden at home
in less time than it takes to have it
delivered i'm not sure what olive garden
did but you should try this version
thanks everyone for coming along on this
journey let me know in the comments
below what i should make next if you
have fun follow me along on instagram
chef.joe.sasto that's me
for food recipes pasta fun we'll have a
great time together but until then i
will see you
later oh yes
[Music]
you